hello everybody I hope that you are good
the new week has started and yesterday I
made this projection okay this was
posted on Twitter in the Sunday update
and I was expecting at the start of the
week on Monday a retrace towards the
50ma in the four hour time frame okay
what I was expecting was you know this
imagine this is the continuation of the
50ma I was expecting a retest a support
and then a bounce then some kind of
sideways on Tuesday like this
and on Wednesday I Spike hope to hit all
these liquidations okay then a rejection
this is an imbalance okay and then fill
this imbalance before the weekend as you
can see that you know we've already
started with the wrong foot because you
can see that Bitcoin one Bitcoin that
retrace but it went below the 50ma
what does this mean
okay this means that what I put on
Twitter the validation for this
projection is that the EMA comes like
this and then Bitcoin hits it again as
resistance and then yes maybe see a
small reaction then price might come
back up okay some kind of sideways below
resistance
towards the 50 of this week okay so
that's what I scenario that might be
happening now in the other hand if you
go to the one hour time frame we can see
the
something might be developing here okay
let me remove this for you so it's not
confusing okay what about
let me remove these two
okay
we've had a dump in the Asian session
you can see here okay and well this this
candle was a vile that was like a one
thousand dollar Scandal that's that's
crazy and then we had a tiny bit of
consolidation another dump and it left
this long week behind so we're expecting
this week to get filled at some point
okay let me Mark it here
and that's the 50 of the week okay and
now the European season is holding
it basically because it's a bank holiday
in most European countries it's a labor
day okay so the banks are closed the
institutional Traders you know half the
day off so really there is not much
happening in the European session
but this brings me to the idea what
about if we see something like this
within the New York session okay
at right at the start of the New Year
session I would like to see a sharp Doom
okay that would be a stop hunt in my
opinion to fill this week the 50 at the
list of the week okay but I could go to
the 100 or even shoot the lose let's
draw like this for now and then
a retrace of this imbalance I mean why
not
we could say this let me see what is the
50 main one out I mean the most likely
thing is that if this happens and we see
a pump that this EMA in the 100 time
frame accessory system so you know that
will be a safer take profits in my
opinion but that would be an idea I I
just I I don't think it's a good place
to Short
okay neither too long we are now in no
man's land in this zone now this is my
plan for today okay what I'm expecting
right at the start of the New York City
units are doom to fill this week okay
now at this point we could see price
continuing going lower or what I'm going
to be paying attention is in the 15
minutes time frame five minutes time
frame lower time frame if we see a
bounce a quick bounce I'm gonna see if
that bounce left any any imbalance
behind for example like weak let me go
to the five minutes time frame because I
don't want to see something like this
you see this long week here I don't want
to see this if I see this but on a
bounce I'm not gonna be long in this
because I know this a week is going to
get retraced okay
let me go to the one hour time frame so
at this point here if I see a bounce in
lower time frame then without any
violence behind I'm gonna open along and
I'm going to close it in the one hour
50ma that's the plan I have today then
the stop loss is going to be quite tight
okay it's going to be probably around
this one here
around this one here so that's what I
have in mind for today let me tell you
this guys when we have very big
important data or news announcements
coming in the next following days
I would say especially fomc you know
with the fat the fat meeting and the CPI
data or earnings reports you know very
important and heavy news that the market
can react to okay then you should in
principle expect that time to be a very
difficult time to trade
so when we are in those type in those
weeks
that we know are going to have big
important news
then I think we should be more selective
with our trades because they're gonna
get more complex
okay saying that you have to have a more
tight risk management in my opinion
that's why for example I'm planning just
to take this day but I'm you know not
100 confident so I'm gonna have in my
stop-loss here quite tight
okay
if this gets triggered I'm not losing
much
you can see 50 sorry 0 to 50 zero to
five that's nothing zero to five percent
is nothing
if I win
I'm making two and a half percent okay
this is what I mean you have to be more
selective for your trades
there might be days where we don't trade
that's okay you don't have to feel bad
about it because you're gonna have other
days
that you're gonna be able to make that
profit okay that's for example what we
don't trade at the weekend
because we know that the weekend there
is not much volatility there is not much
liquidity look this weekend look what
happened what is this
this was you know right before the
monthly close and the weekly closed
yesterday but look at this from Saturday
here
that we can change because it was
hilarious
this is the weekend range okay
what is this
do you want to trade this really
or do you prefer to trade this
okay that's what you have to try to
understand so yes that's look it even
seems that maybe New York well New York
is opening in in 45 minutes
so let's see how it goes
this is today's plan my player might not
people might not play out
either way it's not Financial advice
keep an eye on the five minutes time
frame okay
if we come here
like if we come down here and then we
have you know a boundary here you don't
want to see a way like this
because this week is telling me I can't
belong here price is going to come back
to the zone so like if we come here
and we see a bounce but it's more a
bounce like this style okay then yes you
can long
but if we see a week
of course price can continue going lower
okay so that's pretty much everything I
want to say guys I'm gonna also prepare
a video talking about the Bitcoin
dominance because you know I saw in
Twitter everybody calling foreign
guys for for watching
and I'll see you soon